andrew heaney's on the bump this will be
his fifth start
one and one with a four point two six
era he's throwing the ball
really well the last couple starts to
get the dodgers dodgers at the start of
the day a game
up in the national league west at 14 and
seven spooky bets leading things off in
right field
that's out toward right center field
trout is there
first out it's in the book the two out
free pass brings up aj pollock
out toward right field and tailing away
from
brian goodwin but he makes a leaping
catch at the last second he covered a
lot of ground to get to that baseball
off the bat i'm thinking he's going to
try to cut that off and prevent turner
from scoring here is walker
bueller the first pitch strike
percentage last year was about 65
66 percent he's a little below that this
year but
dave roberts thinks he's a start or two
away from rounding into shape and being
walker bueller we expect tommy stella
has a five-game hitting streak he's
batting 286
1-2 ground ball right on cue it off of
[ __ ] and into shadow right beyond him
mookie betts is backing up on it
keeps uh la stella over at first base
so travel back with a man on bellard
could almost shake tommy lestell's hand
in the lead that's skyed out to center
field towering shot aj [ __ ] going
back that is gone
big fly for mike trout two nothing
angels here in the first
going back to getting a mistake breaking
ball
got it trout dead center field ninth
home run
18 rbi that power continues 4 33
distance wise for trout after some firm
fastballs throughout that at bat
bueller comes with a curveball middle of
the plate
trout didn't miss it adds some height to
it as well
spins up there or stays the heart of the
plate trout will not miss that one
eight home runs in the last 11 games for
trout that is impressive power
that is his 294th home run as rendon
lines will descend a nice sliding catch
by aj [ __ ] for the second out
we've seen aj pollock this year with the
good speed and that with
speed and a great break off the bat once
he goes over to second
[ __ ] down at first for austin barnes was
driven in five over his last five games
he's hit
safely in four straight 80s 02. bart
strikes down
two down and remained focused now you
got a big out there but you have
one of the best players in the game
coming up now in mookie beds
no place to put this guy and he aligns
this one into left field to base it
ballinger will score
here comes the throw in from taylor ward
on his way to the plate max muncie and
it's a tie game
on a two out two run single by mookie
bets
bets with his 16th and 17th rbis
and a clutch hit for mookie early in the
ball game
this one in the air to right center
that's going to get down and
head toward the wall cut off by trout
bellinger
will be held at third base and into
second
is taylor second and third two men out
and chris taylor with his third double
of the season oh taylor in scoring
position and
bellinger 90 feet away for max muncie
walked and scored in the second
and it's on the ground left side that's
throw base hit
bellinger scores here comes taylor
behind him 4-2
dodgers for the second consecutive
inning a dodgers come up
with a two-out two-run base hit and for
max muncie
this one has to feel particularly good
muncie with his first hit of the season
with runners in scoring position
that'll bring a smile to his face oh
yeah
he might want the ball big moment now
for rendon who's been swinging the bad
exceptionally well
four straight games with a home run for
anthony rendon
breaking ball toward the corner that is
going to get down and go for extra bases
it goes over the wall it'll
only bring home one that's one of those
ones you just hope it stayed low enough
or hit the low part of that wall
stays hot brandon and continues to swing
the bat well
against walker bueller and the dodgers
75 pitchers thrown by any
longest downing of the years five and
two thirds two starts ago
pulled toward the hole fledger to the
backhand off balance throw
and got him according to the first base
empire lance barrett
that is an incredible play how quickly
he got rid of that baseball in the
transfer how long that throw
is for fletcher that's about as good as
a play you're going to see
all season long two in scoring position
with nobody on here the bottom of the
fifth
that's out toward right center field
mookie betts moving over and he'd dive
he can to get there
randhifa will score fletcher will be
stopped it'll go as a single and an rbi
we're tied at four chance to take the
lead here now
nobody out fletcher at third la stella
at first
4-4 game drought pulls on the left side
muncie with a diving stop throws to
second low throw [ __ ] goes into that
first baseman pose
gets the out the run scores and the
angels lead it 5-4
what a play by max muncie and the
stretch by [ __ ] hernandez
trout thought he had a another hit ends
up getting an rbi out of it what a play
by muncie
face the top of the dodger order mookie
betts is one
for three with two runs batted in he
swings and hammers one
this one's deep to left center field it
is back
it is gone a home run lukey betts ties
the game in the seventh
home run number eight for mookie well
that's the magic number for the dodgers
five runs they are 12-0 this year and
this is the blast that tied it up
pointing right back at you as rendon
swings at the first pitch that's stabbed
by hernandez for the first out of the
angel eighth
solid play slicing back towards him he's
got to judge the curvature of the ball
and timing with the jump does it very
nicely they put bellinger on with an
intentional walk they don't want to face
him now they're going to face
chris taylor he's chopped on the right
side renjifo
fields throws and gets it there in time
all three outs on ground balls handled
by the angel's second baseman dodgers
leave a pair
on here in the ninth max had a single
his last at-bat
that is out toward left field chris
taylor moving back on it onto the track
near the wall
and he will make the catch in front of
the 390 side
another would be home run in every
ballpark but this one
the 02 from mcgee swung on it missed
strike three 96
upstairs mcgee faces five batters and
retires them all so we go to extra
innings taylor will be at second base
max munson trying to get taylor in there
goes taylor down for third
and he is in with a head first slide
well this is interesting because now
it's going to change the defensive
alignment
that's one of those decisions where you
better have it if you're gonna take it
with nobody out
deep to right fail back to the wall
goodwin and he'll make the catch
this will get taylor in the dodgers take
the lead six five so jansen has to face
trout he's faced him seven
times before trout is one for seven call
strike three and the dodgers win the
dodgers with a run in the top of the
tenth
hang on and beat the angels tonight six
to five